[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Donnerstag die vom Sport hat
Norbert Lehmann schönen guten Tag
kein Bus kein Zug kein Flieger am
kommenden Montag wollen die
Gewerkschaften große Teile Deutschlands
lahmlegen
Zankapfel Verbrennermotor auf dem
EU-Gipfel erntet Deutschland mit seinen
Sonderwünschen viel Unverständnis
Protest der krabbenfische sie wären sich
gegen das geplante schleppnetzverbot in
nordseeschutzgebieten
der Montag wird zur Herausforderung für
Pendler und Reisende die Bahn stellt den
Fernverkehr komplett ein auch Flughäfen
machen dicht und auf den Autobahnen
drohen Staus denn die
Dienstleistungsgewerkschaft verdi und
die Eisenbahnergewerkschaft EVG haben
einen Warnstreik angekündigt im Tarif
Konflikt mit Bahn bunt und Kommunen
konkret heißt das ab Montag 0 Uhr wird
einen Tag lang die Arbeit niedergelegt
bundesweit bei der Bahn an fast allen
Flughäfen an einzelnen Straßentunneln
und auch im Schiffsverkehr dazu wird
auch wieder der öffentliche Nahverkehr
bestreikt in sieben Bundesländern Roman
leskova hat mehr
der Weg zur Arbeit mit Bus und Bahn
Montag könnte er in vielen Bundesländern
beschwerlich werden wer die kündigt ab 0
Uhr für 24 Stunden einen Warnstreik an
diesmal gleich für den gesamten
Verkehrssektor
wie als wäre die rufen ungefähr 120.000
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
den Arbeitskampf und angesichts unseres
hohen organisationsgrades im
Verkehrsgewerbe und das Stimmung die
dort herrscht rechnen wir auch ein mit
einer umfassenden streitbeteiligung auch
Flughäfen sollen bestreicht werden von
380.000 Betroffenen die ihre Reise nicht
antreten können spricht der
Flughafenverband eine Besonderheit
dieses Mal auch die
eisenbahngewerkschaft EVG beteiligt sich
am Ausstand so dürfte der Schienen
Fernverkehr als Reise alternative
ebenfalls entfallen
es werden ganze Schichten ausfallen
deswegen empfehlen wir den Reisenden die
am Sonntag mit Bussen und Bahnen im
Fern- und Nahverkehr unterwegs sind vor
allem im Fernverkehr rechtzeitig am Ziel
zu sein weil es durchaus Schichten geben
kann die bereits am Sonntagabend in den
Montag hineingehen die Positionen im
Tarif Konflikt liegen auseinander für
den öffentlichen Dienst fordert wer die
10,5% mehr lohnt mindestens aber 500 €.
die Arbeitgeber bieten bei längerer
Laufzeit 5% in zwei Schritten einen
Inflationsausgleich von 2500 € in zwei
Schritten und eine Anhebung der Jahres
sondern
der Bahnvorstand ist verärgert über das
runde Chaos das ist aus unserer Sicht
was die EVG bezogen auf die Bahn macht
völlig überzogen unnötig und
unverhältnismäßig Selbstwert auf die
autobahnausweichen will droht Probleme
zu bekommen denn auch für die
Autobahngesellschaft ruft wer die zum
Arbeitskampf auf insbesondere überwachte
Tunnel könnten am Montag gesperrt werden
die Arbeitgeber wollen das verhindern
Wagner in Frankfurt am Main welches
Signal geht von diesem warenstreik aus
ja das Signal der Gewerkschaften ist
klar und deutlich
maximaler Druck durch maximale
Ausdehnung dieses sogenannten
warnschlags den man ja fast schon einen
generalwahnstreik nennen kann wenn Verdi
zusammen mit der EVG am Montag das
öffentliche verkehrsleben lahm liegt was
alle Flughäfen geschlossen sind und Züge
Bahnen und Busse in den Depots bleiben
dann heißt das die Gewerkschaft wir mit
aller Macht die Einigung bei den
Tarifverhandlungen in Potsdam am Montag
erzwingen und ob Verdi und EVG mit
Warnstreiks in diesem Ausmaß noch auf
breites Verständnis bei der Bevölkerung
stoßen das darf bezweifelt werden
danke schön nach Frankfurt Peter Wagner
am Montag also der große Warnstreik im
Verkehrswesen manche werden sich da
fragen darf ich bei Streiks zu Hause
bleiben antworten auf diese und andere
Fragen zur Rechtslage haben wir in
unserer heute App
am ersten Mai kommt das
deutschland-ticket das haben die
Verkehrsminister der Länder bestätigt
für 49 Euro im Monat soll dann
bundesweit der Nahverkehr genutzt werden
können viele Detailfragen sind aber
weiter offen zum Beispiel bei der
Mitnahme von Fahrrädern Kindern und
Hunden am 31 März muss noch der
Bundesrat zustimmen
zwei Tage EU-Gipfel in Brüssel dort sind
einige ziemlich sauer auf Deutschland
denn eigentlich sollte längst
beschlossen sein das ab 2035 in der EU
keine Neuwagen mit verbrennermotoren
mehr zugelassen werden doch auf Druck
der FDP stellte die Bundesregierung im
letzten Moment Nachforderungen in
einigen Punkten gab es aber auch
Einigkeit aus Brüssel Florian neuhahn
es sah kurz so aus als gäbe es bei
diesem EU-Gipfel keinen großen Streit zu
dokumentieren dass die EU künftig etwa
gemeinsam Munition für die Ukraine
einkauft das steht bereits vor Beginn
fest
und ich bin wirklich glücklich dass wir
nur fünf Wochen darauf geeinigt haben
doch dann kommt der deutsche Kanzler und
mit ihm ein Thema das nicht auf der
Tagesordnung steht das Aus für Neuwagen
mit Verbrennermotor ab 2035 das hatte
Deutschland gestoppt nach bereits
erzielter Einigung was viele in Brüssel
ärgert
wir können Vereinbarungen nicht einfach
aussetzen es geht ums Vertrauen zwischen
den Institutionen und die
Glaubwürdigkeit unserer Verfahren
dem deutschen Vito haben sich
mittlerweile andere Länder wie Italien
oder Österreich angeschlossen Berlin
verlangt eine Ausnahme damit Neuwagen
die klimaneutrale e-fuels tanken auch
nach 2035 zugelassen werden wenn ich die
Gespräche zwischen der Kommission und
der Bundesregierung richtig verstehe was
die zuständigen Kommissar und den
zuständigen Minister betrifft ist das
alles auf gutem Weg sagt jedenfalls der
Kanzler Scholz ist nicht der einzige der
mit Sonderthema im Gepäck nach Brüssel
gereist ist Emmanuel macron Präsident
aus Frankreich an dem Land das voll auf
Atomenergie setzt will dass die EU diese
Energie offiziell als Klima neutral
anerkennt doch er stößt damit auf
entschiedenen Widerstand anderer und so
hat Europas Gipfel am Ende doch noch
drei Themen gefunden und an diesem Abend
der Frage der umstrittenen e-fuels noch
keine Einigung
tja in Brüssel warum ist der Unmut über
die Bundesregierung und ihre
Sonderwünsche in Sachen efuel zu groß ja
die Kritiker werfen Deutschland vor dass
Deutschland einfach wortbrüchig geworden
ist nicht mehr dazu steht was es vorher
gesagt hat man muss sich vorstellen es
ist monatelang und diesen Kompromiss für
das aus das Verbrennungsmotor verhandelt
worden und haben alle zugestimmt und auf
den letzten Metern verlangten und
Deutschland das ist noch mal
aufgeschnürt wird das ist schlechter
Stil sagen viele hier Scholz musste sich
verteidigen hat sich auch verteidigt hat
gesagt sie hätten immer Bedenken
angemeldet aber die werden nicht richtig
gehört worden seistum wer da nun Recht
hat das Problem ist riesengroß weil
jetzt auch andere Länder Nachverhandlung
verlangen und damit dieser ganze
Kompromiss und das aus das
Verbrennungsmotors eigentlich auf
wackeligen Füßen steht ich glaube die
einzige Lösung ist dass Deutschland
jetzt sehr sehr schnell eine Einigung
findet damit wie gesagt nicht der ganze
Kompromiss hinfällig ist
Informationen live aus Brüssel danke
schön ultra
in Frankreich brodelt es weiter viele
wollen sich nicht mit der Rentenreform
abfinden weder mit der Aussicht
mindestens bis 64 arbeiten zu müssen
noch mit der Art wie Präsident macron
sein Projekt durchgedrückt hat nämlich
mit einem Kniff am Parlament vorbei er
werde nicht nachgeben erklärte macron
gestern in einem Interview die
Demonstranten aber auch nicht eine Art
am Abend eskaliert der Protest die
Polizei sprüht Tränen Gas Randalierer
werfen Steine sie jagen einander durch
die Straßen von Paris während andere zu
Hunderttausenden friedlich demonstrieren
man fragt sich ob die Polizei uns
einschüchtern will ich habe inzwischen
Angst zu demonstrieren ich kann die
Proteste nachvollziehen weil viele mit
dem Gesetz nicht einverstanden sind aber
leider behindern sie auch uns die
Bewohner es ist der 9 große Aktionstag
in Frankreich und es geht längst nicht
mehr nur gegen die Rentenreform es geht
gegen den Präsidenten seinen Politikstil
wie proposition alle Vorschläge ab oder
lässt sie nicht gelten sobald man nicht
seiner Meinung folgt hört er einfach
nicht mehr zu
ohne Parlamentsabstimmung hat macron mit
einem Sonderartikel das unbeliebte
Rentengesetz beschlossen ein
rechtmäßiges Verfahren doch die Mehrheit
im Land hat der damit laut Umfragen
verprellt
wir stehen vielleicht am Anfang einer
neuen gelbwestenbewegung ein
demokratischer Ausweg zeichnet sich
nicht ab das einzige was das verhindern
könnte wäre eine Entscheidung des
Verfassungsgerichts
das Vertrauen in die Institutionen aber
haben hier viele verloren sie erhöhen
stattdessen den Druck blockieren einen
der großen Bahnhöfe der Stadt
wir sind da auch wenn uns macron nicht
will singen sie ihre Parole seit Monaten
schon und derzeit deutet nichts darauf
hin dass sich die Gemüter beruhigen
[Applaus]
die SPD in Nordrhein-Westfalen muss sich
neu aufstellen ihr Spitzenkandidat bei
der letzten Wahl Thomas kutschati ist
als Parteivorsitzender zurückgetreten
interne Kritik an ihm gab es seit seiner
Wahl schlappe vor zehn Monaten zum Bruch
jetzt führte aber eine Personalie bei
der Suche nach einer neuen
Generalsekretärin hatte sich kutschati
für eine eher unbekannte Kandidatin
stark gemacht gegen den Willen seiner
Partei
Ärger hat auch die AFD in Bremen sie
wird bei der Bürgerschaftswahl Mitte Mai
nicht antreten dürfen das entschied
jetzt der Wahlausschuss Hintergrund
schon länger ist die Partei in Bremen so
zerstritten dass zwei landesvorstände
zwei konkurrierende Wahllisten
eingereicht hatten eine unzulässige
doppelbewerbung befand der Ausschuss
jetzt in die USA dort steht tiktok schon
länger unter strenger Beobachtung der
Regierung jetzt droht sogar ein Verbot
tiktok ist vor allem durch lustige
Tanzvideos bekannt geworden im zwischen
hat es sich zu einem rasant wachsenden
sozialen Netzwerk entwickelt vor allem
Jugendliche gehören zu den mehr als
einer Milliarde Nutzer tiktok sammelt
ihre Daten und was macht der chinesische
Mutterkonzern damit heute musste sich
der Firmenchef den Fragen des
US-Kongresses Stellen Alexandra havelin
aus Washington
aus dem ganzen Land sind sie gekommen um
ihre geliebte Videoplattform zu retten
denn die US-Regierung droht mit einem
Amerika weiten Verbot
kann man nicht einfach abschalten es ist
unser Zuhause ein Ort wo wir die
Pandemie überlebt haben wo wir
Beziehungen aufbauen
die App die von mehr als 150 Millionen
Amerikanern genutzt wird gehört zu weit
Dance einem Konzern aus China
US-Politiker sind überzeugt dass die
Daten dadurch in die Hände der
chinesischen Regierung gelangen und
konfrontieren den Chef von tiktok Show
mit ihren Vorwürfen
tiktok überwacht uns und die
Kommunistische Partei Chinas kann das
als Werkzeug nutzen um Amerika als
Ganzes zu manipulieren der Firmenchef
beteuert immer wieder die chinesische
Regierung habe keinen Zugriff auf die
Daten und tiktok werde sie künftig nur
noch in den USA speichern
alle Daten stehen unter dem Schutz des
US-Rechts das sollte die Sorgen
beseitigen dass die Nutzerdaten von
tiktok dem chinesischen Recht
unterliegen könnten
sie versuchen den Eindruck zu erwecken
dass sie sich von Peking und der
Kommunistischen Partei abwenden wollen
dass Sie gute Absichten haben aber die
Zusagen die wir fordern sehe ich heute
nicht
Bedenken gegenüber tiktok teilt auch die
bundesinnenministerin zu Besuch in
Washington ein Komplettverbot in
Deutschland den sie ab das wäre auch
nicht verhältnismäßig aber man muss sehr
stark aufklären dass das eben ein
Konzern ist der staatlich gehalten wird
und wo die Daten natürlich auch
abfließen können die Gegner von tiktok
haben eine große Unterstützung in der
US-Politik die App wird auch zum
Spielball im geopolitischen Konflikt
zwischen China und den USA
für Muslime hat heute der Fastenmonat
Ramadan begonnen von der Morgendämmerung
bis zum Sonnenuntergang verzichten
Erwachsene Gläubige in der Zeit unter
anderem auf Essen und Trinken das Fasten
zählt zu den fünf Säulen des Islam
Schwangere alte und kranke Menschen sind
von der Pflicht ausgenommen der Ramadan
endet in vier Wochen mit dem Fest des
Fastenbrechens
[Musik]
und jetzt an den Nordsee nach Büsum dort
protestierten heute Krabbenfischer vor
der
Agrarministerkonferenz sie fürchten um
ihre berufliche Existenz denn die EU
will das fangen mit Grundschleppnetzen
in ihren meeresschutzzonen verbieten
Grundschleppnetze werden über den
Meeresboden gezogen je nach Bauart und
Gewicht dringen sie mehr oder weniger in
den Grund ein das kann den Lebensraum
dort empfindlich beschädigen die
krabbenfische fangen deshalb mit
speziellen Netzen die haben Rollen und
sind damit für den Meeresboden weniger
gefährlich dennoch will die EU in der
meeresschutzzone der Nordsee auch dieser
Fangmethode spätestens 2030 ein Ende
setzen Kristina Kajaks aus Büsum
sie leben vom Meer und mit dem Meer
deshalb wollen sie heute ein Zeichen
setzen denn die Pläne der EU könnten die
Fischerei im norddeutschen Wattenmeer
für immer verändern
Prozent meiner Berufskollegen absolutes
Berufsverbot wir können nicht ausweichen
wir haben keine Alternative
naturschütze allerdings begrüßen das
geplante Verbot einfach so
weiterzumachen wie bisher sei unmöglich
die Krabbenfischerei Fisch eine Menge
Tiere mit die als Beifang die nicht
gefischt werden sollen und sie hat
wahrscheinlich eine Vergangenheit auch
dazu geführt dass einige Arten
verschwunden sind aus dem Wattenmeer wie
die sandkorallen wieder nagelrochen in
der Katzenhai die noch nicht wieder da
sind und denen in einen geschütztes Wort
mehr auch eine Rückkehr ermöglicht
werden muss Lars Friedrichsen Fischer in
vierter Generation verteidigt sein
Handwerk seine Netze laufen mit Rollen
über den Meeresboden durch die Vibration
werden die Krabben aufgescheucht und
dann in einem sehr engmaschigen Netz
gefangen ein Beifang gäbe es kaum so
sagt er
das ist die traditionelle fangen Methode
mit der wir arbeiten wobei wir auch
keine Alternative mehr haben zu einer
anderen fangen Methode Nordseekrabben
Leben auf dem Meeresboden auch der
Minister weiß die Brüsseler Pläne sind
hier ein Problem pauschal ist verbotenes
Fischerei würde hier ein Ende bedeuten
das kann ich richtig sein gleichzeitig
ist aber auch klar wir bekennen uns zu
Meeresschutz zum Ozean Schutz eine Takt
des Meer ist ihre Lebensgrundlage das
ist auch den Fischern klar sie hoffen
dass ein Kompromiss möglich ist zwischen
Naturschutz und dem traditionellen
Krabbenfang
im US-Bundesstaat Kalifornien sind bei
Unwettern mindestens fünf Menschen ums
Leben gekommen im Großraum Los Angeles
wurden durch einen Tornado Dächer von
mehreren Gebäuden sowie Autos stark
beschädigt seit vielen Wochen gibt es in
Kalifornien ungewöhnlich häufig Stürme
starke Regenfälle sorgen dabei immer
wieder für Erdrutsche und
Überschwemmungen
und jetzt zur Fußball Champions League
da waren gestern auch die
Wolfsburgerinnen erfolgreich nach dem
1:0 Bayern-Sieg im Viertelfinal Hinspiel
gegen Arsenal jetzt das 1:0 des VfL in
Paris unterm Strich ein glücklicher Sieg
gegen PSG auch weil der Videobeweis auf
der Seite der Wölfin war der Showdown
lügt in Paris in der 62 Minute Dominik
Jansen mit dem Siegtreffer
vorausgegangen waren Handspiel Video
Beweis und gelb rot für almeda Paris
eine halbe Stunde in Unterzahl zuvor in
der 54 Minuten für Paris gibt es keinen
Elfmeter der Ball ist von Wolfsburg
gespielt worden
die Spiele werden halt vor allem
taktisch immer anspruchsvoller du musst
Dich anpassen musst immer 100% da sein
Kleinigkeiten entscheiden aber das ist
halt so bei Spielen auf diesem Niveau
am Samstag bundesliga-gipfel Wolfsburg
beim FC Bayern ein Unentschieden reicht
Wolfsburg um an der Spitze zu bleiben
ja und am Samstag auch das erste Spiel
der Fußballnationalmannschaft der Männer
im neuen Jahr gegen Peru nach der
Verletzung von Manuel Neuer wird wohl
Marc-André ter Stegen vom FC Barcelona
im deutschen Tor stehen
er will seine Chance nutzen Stammtorwart
bei der Heim-EM werden Marc André ter
Stegen der seit Jahren starke Leistungen
beim FC Barcelona zeigt ist in
Abwesenheit des verletzten Manuel Neuer
zu neuen Nummer eins aufgestiegen nun
will er den Bayern Keeper auch dauerhaft
verdrängen durch die Verletzung von Mann
oder jetzt gerade nicht da ist ist die
Situation so wie sie ist und ich werde
natürlich versuchen meine Chance zu
nutzen absolut ab dem Peru Spiel trägt
er die Prestige prächtige Nummer eins
auf dem Trikot dann zählen nur noch top
Leistungen um seinem Traumziel em mehr
zu kommen
zur Eiskunstlauf WM in Japan bislang
ohne deutsche Erfolge die Berliner paar
Läufe Annika Hocke und Robert Kunkel
wurden in der Kühe neunte ein
ordentliches Ergebnis nach ihrem eher
schwachen Auftritt im Kurzprogramm der
Titel ging an die Gastgeber Rico Miura
und Joachim gold
auch wie schön und morgen gibt es die
Entscheidung Köder Frauen ab 9 Uhr bei
uns im ZDF Livestream ZDF Mediathek
dankeschön das Wetter bringt Regen Wind
und Gewitter und das Wochenende wird
wieder kälter die Details hat gleich
Katja horneffer viertel vor zehn begrüßt
Sie Christian Sievers im heute-journal
wir sagen danke und tschüss und bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen alles Gute Ihnen
[Musik]
guten Abend wechselhaft geht es in den
nächsten Tagen weiter da sehen sie schon
an diesem Satellitenbild diese
verschiedenen Tiefs die kalt und die
Warmfronten heute Nacht setzt kräftiger
Regen ein der bereitet sich hier bis
morgen früh bis zur Ostsee aus besonders
kräftig regnet es in der Westhälfte am
längsten trocken bleibt es in Sachsen
und in Bayern bei einem starken zum Teil
stürmischen Wind aus südwestlichen
Richtungen so wird das noch mal eine
milde Nacht mit Tiefsttemperatur von 13
bis 7 Grad und morgen erwarten uns
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 11 und 17
Grad der Regen der nach der zieht dann
morgen über Tag ostwärts ab dann lockern
die Wolken auch mal auf und es gibt zum
Teil kräftige Regenschauer und auch
Gewitter morgen Nachmittag in der
Westhälfte sein am längsten regnen wird
es im Osten und auch im Süden
Deutschlands der Winter zu dreht ist
immer noch kräftig und kommt aus West
südwestlichen Richtung der Samstag den
Kräft ige Regenschauer und Gewitter und
stürmischen Wind bei Temperaturen von 9
bis 14 Grad am Sonntag ziehen über die
Mitte und den Süden kräftige Regenfälle
entdeckt und dann wird es mal ganz
kälter dann kann es vorübergehend auch
im Flachland am Montag mal weiß werden
guten Abend